joe what's everything you take
everything everything that was sexual
most of it most of it is like the the
big results come from testosterone
replacement and then there's peptides
that increase your body's ability to
grow uh hormones like growth hormone
yeah this bbc one five seven hypermoral
you've googled bbc i'm [ __ ] these
names up and then another one's called
thymusin and what these things do is
they uh
they help your body produce the hormones
that it should have when you're younger
and your body works better and if you do
that and you
regularly exercise if there's ever one
thing that someone can do to stop aging
it's lift weights and don't stop and
don't do it for vanity do it because you
want to keep your tissue you have to
lift heavy things and you have to you
don't want to do anything too heavy when
you hurt yourself but you want to get
your body accustomed to this idea that
in order to survive it has to lift
things and you need to give that body
nutrients